three high-ranking florida officials are
expressing their frustration because
they say ems was delayed getting inside
Stoneman Douglas high school on the day
of the shooting in the critical moments
when victims lay inside in need of
immediate care one source tells FOX News
some EMS teams requested to go inside
but were denied by the commanding agency
the Broward County Sheriff's Office that
source alleges scanner recordings will
reveal that now the Broward County
Sheriff's Office released a statement in
response to some of these allegations
saying in part there are multiple
investigations being conducted in
addition to the Stoneman Douglas
shooting investigators will not be
rushed or asked to jump to conclusions a
reporter from our Miami affiliate WSVN
reports that a seasoned first responder
said they would have risked their life
to go inside and that they were
frustrated the entire time they were
there however the Coral Springs parkland
fire chief who was on scene that day
says it is procedure that EMS cannot go
inside until law enforcement clears them
to enter the fire chief says law
enforcement could not initially confirm
if the suspect fled or was deceased
making it too dangerous to let EMS
inside that fire chief telling Fox News
in part decisions cannot be made in a
vacuum it is possible that those that
are upset about not being allowed inside
simply do not have all the information
that our law enforcement partners had in
making their decision the Florida
Department of Law Enforcement is
investigating all the actions by the
Broward County Sheriff which will
hopefully shed light on the timeline of
that day I know a lot more than you all
do now so all I'm going to say is yes I
believe there needs to be a full
investigation I don't think some people
were honest and we're going to
investigate this in Florida and the
right thing will be done Tucker a Rules
Committee in the Florida Senate today
voted down a proposal on a statewide ban
on assault weapons here in Florida
Tucker man thanks a lot